Shepard Perret in your book about
ulysses s grant you write this on page
274 many who met him were left feeling
slightly puzzled some felt more or less
cheated he did not look like a great
general did not talk like a great
general did not dress like a great
general and did not even appear to
consider himself a great general and
then you say maybe he wasn't so great
after all but of cause I believe that he
was I simply am suggesting there that
that maybe there is something to the
criticism but I think it's fundamentally
misplaced that there are good reasons
why people didn't consider grants a
great general at the time I think in
retrospect is pretty obvious that he was
a very great general indeed I was simply
being a little provocative that by
saying maybe he wasn't I certainly
believe that he was why did you do this
book on u.s. grant when I was a freshman
at Hollywood High School many years ago
Ricky Nelson was my classmate and a
history teacher mentioned that not
trying considered grant grants memoirs
to be the greatest memorized by generals
in season now I knew nothing about
Caesars memoirs and I really didn't know
anything about grant but a week or so
earlier I had read Huckleberry Finn and
I had stayed up most of the night to
finish it and I felt that anyone who
could write a book like that who thought
somebody else was a great writer was on
to something so I read the two volumes
and there intimidating-looking volumes
advance memoirs at first I thought this
is going to be too difficult and instead
I was simply bowled over so we came
fascinated by Christ when when I went in
the army and became an army journalist I
suppose it may have been inevitable at
that point that one day I would like to
write a book about crack but I didn't
realize that then
the proximate causes lawyers say so what
I was writing my biography of Douglas
MacArthur old soldiers never die I had
to confront the question that will in
Manchester confronted he concluded that
MacArthur was the greatest soldier the
United States had ever produced and I
couldn't rate encounter as the best I at
most I would say it was number two
because he created too many problems for
his superiors during World War two as
far as I knew grant hadn't done that he
had not made difficulties for Lincoln
but I still didn't having read the
memorize they still did not understand
the nature of grants genius and in order
to find it out I had to write this book
how important is in our history it is
fundamental
no grant and there is no victory in the
Civil War for the Union the Civil War
would have probably ended in a stalemate
with a negotiated peace rather than a a
silent now what kind of peace that would
be I don't know but I believe that Grant
was the only general who could
coordinate the Union strength and
bringing to bear on the Confederacy in
time to ensure Lincoln's reelection in
1864 when did he live oh he's born in
1822 and I Hamlet in Ohio he didn't live
long enough he died at the age of 63 a
victim with those cigars that he smoked
he was a very heavy cigar smoker during
the Civil War for fairly obvious reasons
I suppose and he got cancer of the
oesophagus and died in 1885 and of all
the times in his life that you write
about when would you like to have been
around him almost any time I
I would love to have been with granted
at certain moments in his life I would
love to be with granted Mexico grant
time in Mexico was absolutely essential
to his education of the soldiers what
year was 1846 to 1847 and he was
immensely proud Graham is a
fundamentally modest man but he was
immensely proud but he had participated
in 10 battles in Mexico and he used to
tell people you couldn't be in more than
10 battles in Mexico
he'd been in in northern Mexico when
Zachary Taylor led an American army into
Mexico and then when the was shifted to
the south and Winfield Scott advanced on
Mexico City grants regiments was with
Winfield Scott so he dissipated is
because he used to say it has many
battles as anyone in Mexico and it was
then that grant discovered that although
he'd applauded the human cost of war he
was susceptible to the drum and once he
found a way to participate in a battle
feeling that he was doing his duty that
this death and destruction could could
be justified on moral grounds I think he
really discovered that he had a
soldier's vocation and that came as a
surprise to him
where did he live in his life he never
really had a home he was essentially a
man who had no geographical roots
although he's born in Ohio he left there
when he was comparatively young and in
because of his life he lived in Barrie's
an army barracks he had lived his
father-in-law's property in near st.
Louis he lived in the field
he lived in borrowed houses during the
civil war at the end of the war he was
given a house in Washington he lived
there only
only short time and then he after he
left the White House I would rival in
the White House he had at a cottage at
Long Branch New Jersey was gave a summer
White House
well the forerunner of the summer White
House and he would go there just to get
away from Washington but he said he then
had a home in New York after he spent
two-and-a-half years traveling around
the world he also had a home in Galena
but he didn't like Galena
be like at Killeen Illinois he didn't
like Galena very much he thought he
would never be able to afford to live in
New York and then he was given a house
in New York but then he went bankrupt
and lost the house in New York he lost
the house in Long Branch and he died in
somebody else's house he died in a
holiday cottage a vacation cottage of a
Mount McGregor in upstate New Year and
that tooth said something about grants
he really did see himself as just
passing through this life where is he
buried he is buried in New York but that
was not his choice that was his wife's
choice grant wanted to be buried at West
Point and he wanted his wife should be
buried alongside him at that time you
could not be buried at West lines unless
you were a West Point graduate your wife
certainly couldn't be buried with you
now had Grant ever expressed any desire
to have his wife buried with him at West
Point I have no doubt that Congress
would have passed whatever bill was
necessary but on the other hand grant
was the last man in the world ever to
ask for a favor so he kept his mouth
shut
he told his wife I would like to be
buried at West Point you cannot be
buried with me so once I'm gone you
decide where I will be buried the
important thing was that she would be
buried alongside him how long was he
married well when he came back from
Mexico in 1847 he was finally able to
marry his fiancee they've been engaged
for four years at that time the war had
that kept them apart along with the
opposition opposition of her parents to
this marriage when he came back first
thing he did was was marrying Julia then
and they were married for the next 36
years let me ask you about this picture
right here
well this picture shows
Julia Julia with the Grant's daughter
and Nellie
can't you get actually sit back okay
sorry who deli and the elderly gentleman
with the cane is Julie's father who was
it remained a Democrat all his life a
secessionist all his life and
continually told Matt you had not a true
Republican you're really a Democrat and
the Confederacy was right and the Union
was wrong he was very argumentative and
cantankerous old man very strong
opinions but ironically he ended up
spending his finally is living in the
White House and he died in the White
House and the young fella and his grant
youngest son Jesse how many children did
the u.s. grant him he had four three
girls sorry three boys and ago where did
he get his name you ask grant well he
was baptized Hiram Hiram Ulysses Grant
and when he went to West Point he
foresaw the future his luggage was going
to have the initial of hqg and he was
going to be known as hug because
everybody at West Point has an exam and
he didn't what we call hug so when he
got to West Point he said my name is he
reverted to the adjutant said my name is
Ulysses as grant Ulysses Hiram grants
and the adjutant said no it's not your
name is Ulysses s cracks the congressman
who had appointed him had made this
appointment the very last day of his
term in Washington and so the
congressman was probably surrounded by
packing
in cases and just preparing to get out
of town he has a lot of things to sign I
think what is that grant boy's name and
something Ulysses Ulysses something and
he writes down ulysses s grant because
grants mother's maiden name was Simpson
so the congressman so we knew that the
father called him Ulysses he had to have
a middle initial some kind guess that it
was asked for Simpson and the adjutant
then explained to Ulysses Grant that
because the appointment said it was made
out of the name of ulysses s grant that
was who he was as long as in the arm he
was in the army that was who he would be
and he accepted it there was no Hyrum
there no chance of being called hug and
then lacy is when people asked him what
does the s in your name stand for he
said nothing just like Harry Truman page
430 right it helps to explain why he was
a mystery to contemporary such as
Sherman and others who have studied him
since whether as admiring as Bruce
Catton
or as disdainful as William McFeely
who's Bruce Kenton who's William McFeely
and why were they why was Bruce Catton
admiring and way McFeely disdainful
booth captain erisa most successful
writer on the Civil War he was an editor
of American heritage and a wonderfully
fluent stylist and his passion to sue
counselor very strongly in his writing
bruce catton in effect popularized the
civil war if anyone did with his both
fathers in the 50s and the 60s and he
took on the task of completing a
multi-volume biography of grant the
first volume was done by Lloyd Lewis who
died shortly after it was published
Kattan then assumed the responsibility
for continuing this work and Canton
produced two volumes on Grant during the
Civil War and once his civil war was
over
I don't think Katherine was interested
in writing about Grant and the
presidency so that thought that
multi-volume by
our grant was never finished by the way
is Bridge Kenton alive no burrs captain
died some years ago did you know him
alas now where was he from where did he
well he was born in a small town in
Michigan was I mean his very tiny place
and that's where he's buried he died
about 15 years ago something like that
how many of his books have you read
well it seems like a lot but I wouldn't
claim to read all of them I must have
read I read his wonderful volley from
the Army of the Potomac
I read the Centennial history and I've
read the grandpas and he did a volume on
the generalship
military legacies of grant how much did
he admired you asked me tremendously but
I much as I like captain and I respect
his work tremendously I don't think the
Katan really understood grant very well
and you'll find in that book but much of
it really is a refighting of the war
there is one place where for 20 pages
grantees and even mentioned and many
people write about the Civil War
cat and ended up refighting the whole
war and the focus is not rude truly on
grants I don't think it is it really is
a biography of grant it's about grant
and the Civil War where McFeely well
they disdained him well yes yeah I think
it's fair to say that and McFeely is a
professor and his biography of grant was
published in 1981 but won the Pulitzer
Prize cognate times Bancroft prize and I
believe the reason why it was so
immensely favored was that the timing
was right for a Borgia that was
essentially dismissive with Brant it was
published when the Vietnam wound was
still throbbing so still suffering and
people still wanted to know who was to
blame for this man
and to hold America's greatest soldier
up to ridicule I think was therapy but I
don't think the great pound you know
professor McFeely no I don't see you a
lot yes I blue so I noticed that I
really extracted that on several pages
you bring him up and this still would
get the flavor of it I'll read some of
it
grants most hostile biographer William
McFeely states forthrightly the grant
was lying but there is no independent
evidence of this earlier say grants
prize-winning biographer William McFeely
believes that in turning a demonstration
in to attack grant was insubordinate
this ignores the fact that in the 19th
century field commanders had
considerable leeway to interpret their
orders much more so than in these days
of instant and secure communications you
can go I go on that maybe reads more
grants biographer Wade McFeely would
says unequivocably that grant perjured
himself to say Babcock he offers no
evidence to substantiate this remarkable
contention did you think a lot about
whether to take on believe McFeely in
your book like this I could have buried
this kind of thing in the footnotes
which is what academics tend to do but
I'm not a professor and my view is that
if McFeely can condemn grant as false
rightly as he does hold him up to scorn
and ridicule then it is only fair for me
to point out to the reader that this is
a very different book from McFeely and I
don't want anyone to come away from
reading my book feeling that I have a
void abduct this issue because when I
was working on this book I was asked
time and again how is your book going to
different from McFeely
and I said totally for for various
reasons but I believe for instance I
take fifty pages to describe on what
granted in the Civil War
professor McFeely deals with grant in
the Civil War in what amounts to one
page and treats it as if grant achieved
nothing in civil
they said to require a taste about
have you ever done that before in any
yearbooks oh yes I criticized mattress
in my books on the console how many
books have you written nine and what
kind in fiction 19 well I've written I
published one novel the other eight
books are nonfiction they I've written
social history and political history but
mostly I have written military history
and military biography also you never
die was the character biography what
were some of the others well that was my
first biography before that I wrote a
book about the air force in world war ii
called wing victory before that i wrote
a book about the army in world war ii
called
there's a war to be won before that I
wrote in military history of the United
States from the revolution to Vietnam
called the country made by war before
that I wrote a book on the homefront in
my first book was a book on the
homefront in world war ii called days of
sadness years of trying and the sequel
to that was a book about America after
World War two up to the death of John
Kennedy called the dream of greatness
and then I wrote a book about the 1920s
as a very simply fascinated me called
simply America in the twenties so I've
written political history social history
cultural history as well as military
history and now I'm writing a biography
of Dwight Eisenhower where I get to
write post military history biography
and political history and biography in a
single volume have you always been a
writer I've always wanted to be a writer
I I have been a writer since I got out
of Houston well since I stopped being a
student being student was wonderful but
I couldn't carry down forever
where we used to I was a law school at
ball called the University of California
Berkeley I as it graduates to school at
Harvard and before that I did my
undergraduate work at the University of
Southern
California where'd you grow up well my
parents are in showbiz I grew up in a
lot of places
I graduated from 23 schools before I
finish high school I'm sorry I attended
23 schools before I graduated from high
school you know what kind of places all
kinds of places but mostly in in England
and the United States my my mother's
English my cousin's American and they
come from show people five generations
on both sides and we my father would
also work in France mine it was school
and trunk what were your parents names
well my father's name was Vic Perry and
he had a TV show on Chicago in the early
50s and having succeeded as he shot on
the small screen we moved to Hollywood
for a couple of years and he he was into
movies but he couldn't remember the
lines he couldn't remember one three and
five so you could not make a career out
of in the movies if that's all you can
remember so we moved back to Chicago but
we were constantly moving around
particularly in the days of the
nightclubs which extended into the mid
fifties and he'd be working clubs saying
Miami or New York or Boston or Chicago
and my parents would put me a stroll say
for a week how about your mom was she
sure anything yes she was she had been a
dancer until she had two children where
do you live now
well unlike most writers I think I live
mostly in my head but I I'm more or less
I'm carrying on the the transatlantic
commute that my parents got me involved
in it used to be on the ocean liners and
now it's it's on airplanes and my wife
is an assistant principal in the high
school in England so I spent much of the
year there and I spend the rest of it
here do you do anything else but write
today no and how long did you work on
the grant buyer
it depends on how you counted see I had
written a military history of the u.s.
from the revolution to Vietnam so just
had to write about the Civil War and so
this was really my second attempt to
write about the Civil War so I had some
background from having written about it
before but nothing anything like the
steps that this required and I would say
had I started from scratch he might have
taken me four years to do this book and
it took me two and a half someone buys
this book what do they get what they get
what I hope was very fast folks thank
you mrs. s grant from start to finish
yes I include the presidency this isn't
simply about grandpa soldier this is
pranced the president's as well as Pratt
facility and grant the president turned
out to be a surprise it's when I was in
college I did the one-year survey course
of American history I had an excellent
teaching and I remember that afternoon
he stood he said now we will consider
the rating of the president and this was
where we're dealing with the Gilded Age
said at the top we see the faces of
George Washington and Abraham Lincoln
Thomas Jefferson we moved down to the
middle we have people like Grover
Cleveland and we keep on moving down and
as we look down towards the earth
what do we see staring up in the bearded
village of ulysses s Kratz and the only
thing the law grants is the eyebrows of
Warren Gamaliel Harding so must be
pretty bad as a president and this saw
and mix then professor McFeely Stokes
was mostly about grant the failed
president well it came as a surprise to
me to discover that grant was not a
failed president he was not a great
president but he was a confident
middle-of-the-road president there were
a lot of scandals associated with his
administrate
but that was comparatively new financial
scandals were not a god of the
presidency until the Civil War because
until then America was a country that
what people didn't have a lot of money
the government didn't have a lot of
money the Civil War prison seen a huge
national debt and the more than four
hundred billion dollars and greenbacks
were put in circulation so now there's a
lot of money around and money changes
people and it changed America so grant
becomes the president reconstruction
which should have been the big moral
crusade following the Civil War has been
killed stone dead by Andrew Johnson and
grant couldn't revive it Lincoln could
not have revived it in that condition
and the biggest problem of government
faced was the national debt the turn 1/2
billion dollar national debt how do we
pay meantime you have the rise of
industrial America and there's a lot of
money around railroad companies happy to
bribe any congressman they can show a
money antov and with all these scandals
swirling around him grant was in the
unique position he was the first
president who had to cope with a lot of
financial scandals and people were
horrified what has happened to our
government we have all these financial
scandal but he's the era that has
changed that's not one man no man could
have stopped that and I think ever since
since the Gilded Age most American
administrations have had their financial
scandals but grant gets blamed in effect
because he was the first what years was
he president 1869 to 1876 how did he get
elected narrowly he got elected really
because the white vote vote was split
50-50 and during the Democrats and the
Republicans
it was the blacks who were allowed to
vote for the first time who rarely put
Francis at the White House and they
brought about 1868
this this is the election of 1868
population back then 1868 60mm number of
blacks in the country then I probably
lost I'm around eight nine million
percentage that he won by the only one
by a couple I might permit 51% to 49%
his opponent was a ratio seem well
governor New York with a very competent
politician and because many people felt
the cyma would have made a better
president
did he campaign grant no see what I did
which was unusual zero nearly won the
election be and one of the reasons
wasn't SEMA actually went out on the
hustings until then presidential
candidates let other people through the
campaigning they did not go out and
actively campaign themselves where was
grant living when he ran he had more or
less retreated or gone into exile in
Galena in his gift house in Kalina
because he wanted to get as far away
from Andrew Johnson as he could what do
you mean by gift house well the people
of Galena gave him a house just as the
people in Philadelphia the people of
Philadelphia given him a house and he
spent virtually no time in the house in
Philadelphia spent some time in the
house in Kalina he wouldn't he didn't
want to be in glee and he just didn't
want to be in Washington while Andrew
Johnson was here why not
well they hated each other Johnson
represented almost everything grant this
v Johnson had tried to to use grants to
knows a sharp his own crumbling
popularity but Johnson had undermined
sabatons
reconstruction which to someone like
grants was a a cause that Lincoln
favored and the the nation needed the
racial problems after the Civil War not
and I've been resolved by the civil wars
they by abolition savory that slavery
did not solve the problem if the
integration of black people into
Americans who
and reconstruction was the project that
logically should have followed on from
the Civil War Andrew Johnson reverted to
being a southern Democrat as soon as who
are ended and did everything he could to
make reconstruction virtually impossible
and only the military could have pushed
reconstruction through what does it mean
reconstruction how big was it well it I
don't think there could have been
anything much bigger because the issue
was how to do these all these millions
of freed slaves become responsible
members of American society and granted
first of all they should not get the
vote until they could at least learn to
read and write but he later came to see
that there wasn't enough time for that
that it would have to be done the other
way around and he felt that even if they
could people had trouble reading and
writing and did not have much education
they were still citizens and she'd still
be entitled to vote so he saw the
enfranchisement of black people as the
solution to the problem that
reconstruction post and Johnson on the
other hand was telling Congress I am
opposed to the African ization of half
of our country and obstructed the
military that every time grants was the
commanding general of the armies and was
trying to use the military to advance
reconstruction Johnson did whatever he
could to block that project Congress the
Radical Republicans in Congress were on
Grant side with this he never became a
Radical Republican but he was very close
to them in some respects a couple
messages you get in your book the US
Grant hated Washington that his wife
loved it that he was the youngest man
ever to be elected to president 46 years
old when he got there that people who
went after him did know he's Republican
or Democrat there's some similarities in
history you know you think you're
writing a book on the Dwight Eisenhower
you know did they go who went after take
those two men both generals both
successful generals who went after each
one of them to get them to run the
moderates the people by the time of the
1868 election most people that had as
much radicalism as they could take the
war itself was an emotionally draining
experience they fight over
reconstruction was also a draining and
bitter experience and what people were
looking for was somebody who wasn't too
radical he not radically in favor of
reconstruction and not radically opposed
to reconstruction and the one person
they knew believed was essentially a
moderate a political moderate who they
could turn to was grant and although I
haven't reached his price in my own
workshop on Eisenhower my my very strong
impression and recollection is that
grant really did appeal to the very
broad middle-of-the-road constituency
that is in that is really the probably
the biggest political grouping in
American democracy what was the
situation in Galena how old were his
kids
well Johnson had tried to win grant over
by pointing his elder son Fred to West
Point and people tend to forget that
they said think he granted his memoir so
I said I was not happy at West Point
inside you know I always loads West
Point atrocities loved it he just didn't
like the West Point system but he
actually loved the institution it meant
a great deal to him so it was important
to him to have his older son go to West
Point not to pursue a military career
but to be a West Point Man he had two
other sons the youngest was
jessie was a child when when grant was
in the White House where's this picture
that picture was taken at City point
this is the only one of the tens of
thousands of cabins that the army built
during the Civil War that is still with
us and Julie you're standing in profile
in the doorway Julie had strabismus in
her right eye so you very rarely see
pictures of Julie looking at the camera
this there's young Jesse there's Grant
sitting in the chair this is towards the
end of the war this is in in the winter
of 1864 at City Park for Kenny so four
years later in Galena kids julia is
sitting there who comes after him
directly and says we want you to run who
did he ask him oh yeah well no they if
they had asked him outright do you want
to be President I think they knew the
answer was no you never had asked a
question unless you prefer to live with
the answer so a bandwagon was created by
the various factions within the
Republican Party who knew that only way
of holding on to the White House was to
push grants into it and essentially
that's what they did and it's done Julia
asked him
ulis do you want to be president in
sciences no but you think he's got to
happen anyone describe him at that's
what he looked like
how tall was he well he sometimes
described as being short but he was five
feet eight which for that time was
slightly above average height the thing
is grant was grant slump he was round
soldiered he was so he had absolutely no
military bearing whatever and he took
about two inches off his height just
from the way he sat and the way he
walked he was always hunched over and he
seemed to to fold in on himself likely
the way some people do and he made so he
made himself looks smaller than he
really was
he was always worried that he was thin
and consumptive so when he got into the
White House and started putting on
weight he was immensely pleased because
he read he saw putting on weight as a
sign of robust good health but most of
his life he was with a slender fellow
it's five feet eight but looked like
this London feller was about five five
five six but when you saw him up close
what does his clothes look like his
shoes and his word and he keep himself
well yes but it's a bit and I'll know
he's a modest man he had his own way of
making statement grant used to wear a
privates flap but were the general studs
as if to say he was both the pride a
private soldier and an officer where he
had been tried with both this was
towards the end of his life when he was
a a stock boy he had a Wall Street firm
he wasn't a stockbroker
he had a Wall Street financial fund I
was a partner in the funds it was that
really turned out to be a huge pyramid
scheme he know it
now he had the clue most of the people
on Wall Street didn't know it the
president of the Erie Railroad didn't
know it came down and said he had taken
hundreds of thousands of dollars of my
money now would be millions and invested
they thought it was a big investment
scheme but we now so familiar with these
pyramid schemes of Ponzi schemes were
that we know we can usually smell them
from a long way off but they were fairly
new then and this one was very close
because we hadn't they had a bank
fronting for the scheme as you said
earlier the elected president fifty one
fifty two percent goes to the White
House two and a half billion dollar
deficit what's that relate to today well
it's impossible to really translate that
except anything to say that if people
are worried about it five trillion
dollar deaths this was to that time on
the same scale did the country care
about it then yes they probably some
senators and congressmen
claimed that the the debt was the
biggest problem the country faced and
not reconstruction you say he had
planted six cabinet officers yes
maybe now we've got what 14 or 15 canon
officers people that we would know names
we would know well probably only
Hamilton fish his Secretary of State who
has generally considered one of the
three great secretaries of states in
American history what was the White
House itself like it was pretty informal
what and when Lincoln and Johnson was
the president couldn't treat it like a
home and really presidents didn't treat
it like a home Julia was the one who
changed it she had three children living
with her at the time three children to
raise and she was determined to create a
home for them in the White House and so
she had the gates lots of the children
to play on the White House long as I
couldn't have people staggering in the
half-drunk and passing out under the
trees on the South Lawn and she made the
staff improve their appearance she had
the whole interior redone them it was
chipped paint it was broken furniture
Julie got rid of the chipped paint and
the broken furniture and set it into a
comfortable Pleasant home for herself
and a husband and the three children and
that was really the first time anybody
had done that with the White House how
much drinking did he do in his life not
a lot here it is ironic the most famous
drunk in American history it was not a
heavy drinker the trouble was grant was
that he get drunk on two drinks and not
only that he would start walking into
the furniture I mean I need the wall for
support if I was obvious that the grass
had been drinking some people we know
she could drink a bottle and you would
never guess when he was the other way
around and there was really only one
reason why grant drank and that was he
was deeply and passionately in love with
his wife grants marriage was not a
limited partnership
it was a romance from beginning to end
and when he was away from Julia for very
long
he felt desperately lonely he missed it
tremendously and he was not drinking
it's also true that during the Civil War
after some big battle grant would have a
couple of drinks and that was where as a
release of tension but while it's
preparing for a battle while battle was
in progress and ever touches and stuff
the essential thing is the absence of
Julia the absence of the presence of a
bottle in Grant's town invariably
indicated an absence of Julia and when
the war ended and he doesn't spend all
of his time with his wife he hardly ever
touched anything so maybe to sip food
glass of champagne at the state banquet
in the White House what were the major
scandals that he found during the eight
years White House well the the two
biggest were the Credit Mobilier scandal
which involved a railroad company and
that wasn't really grant scandal during
the the Johnson administration Credit
Mobilier
had paid off at least 50 congressmen and
this camp well gave him stock in the
company but didn't and as the fat and
the stock rose in value but they hadn't
had to pay for the stock and people
considered themselves as exemplary moral
exemplary moral politicians such as
James Garfield took the stock Democrats
took the stock Republicans took the
stock to read the finance company for
the railroad needed a grant from the
government huge amount of land with the
land as collateral legged any - County
who then raised money they get a
mortgage on the on the land the
important thing was to get Congress to
approve giving huge amounts of federal
land well credit mobilier they handed
out the stock was able to finance the
railroad so the fact the stock rises in
value
the start was given away roses in value
and in Congressman haven't declared that
they in effect they have a financial
interest in it
the scandal breaks but it breaks during
the grant administration and somehow
granted is blamed tarnished by what was
really an Andrew Johnson scandal simply
because it comes to light during grants
presidency the other big scandal is the
whiskey fraud scandal for some time in
border states the way Democrats had
financed their political campaigns was
to siphon off some of the whiskey tax
that was imposed during the Civil War as
a way of helping to finance the war so
the district collected tax collectors
would send some of them and some of the
money over to the federal government but
they would keep some of it back to
finance political campaigns and
Democrats did this in in border states
they say and after the Civil War the
Republican Party was very dependent in
in 1872 particularly on a big-time
banker called Jay cook and cook went
bankrupt so when the so after the 1872
election the Republican Party means a
new moneybags
and it cannot find one so so the
Republicans in some states start
engaging their own whiskey tax fraud in
order to finance Republican campaigns
and this happened in in several places
grant had no idea this was going on it
was it was the problem we doing now how
do we campaign finance this problem is
still he but the solution for some
people then was to take some of the
whiskey tax money grant wasn't aware of
that
his secretary one of the secretaries
although Babcock a an army officer was
involved in that grant never believed
that the Babcock was involved with
Grandma simply wrong Babcock was
involved but we got him Babcock was not
profiting personally from this it was
for the good as a Republican party your
party square it was it conscience and
besides the Democrats were doing the
same thing
his brother Orville oh well I mean
Oliver was a complete scapegrace and it
over was a bad seed of the grant family
and for a while before the Civil War
when Grant worked in his father's
leather store and Galena probably the
most humiliating God of the whole
business was that he had to take orders
from Orville have been working in the
store for years he had as little to do
with Ovilus as he could and I will
embarrass him several times during his
time in the White House by one point
boneville and somebody else managed to
swindle some widow after the $5,000 that
a husband had left it and novel had no
conscience no scruples how many places
did you travel that were that has the
name Grant stamped on really like the
Galena home and things like that did you
ever you make those cracks no I did
travel but in the case of Grant most of
his papers here in the Library of
Congress and what most of what isn't
here can be found elsewhere such as
Carbondale Illinois way which is
Southern Illinois University has the the
grant papers project and so wherever
there were papers I went and I went to
City point to visit the cabin at City
Park where is that well city proper
jinyu's it's down on the James River you
open up with your knowledge miss by
saying my greatest debt is to dr. John
why Simon who has acquired an unrivaled
knowledge of grant during the 35 years
it is edited grants papers John's
impeccable scholarship is surpassed only
by a generosity of spirit such as I have
rarely encountered and shall never
forget explain more I think with the
privilege to be able to write the
phocion grant because they came to like
him so much but the the other great
privilege was getting to know John Simon
who is one of the finest people I've
ever met
what is it about John time that is
different from others you have contact
with in your eight books other eight
books you're in well he isn't the only
fine person I'm bad but John represents
someone who I'm sure grant would would
have admired the people who added papers
presidents papers tend to begin with
fair amount of enthusiasm and commitment
but after 20 years something else comes
along are they simply retired but John
took on this project
Ron Mel 35 years ago and he stayed with
it ever since
and his commitment to it combined with
the tremendous research effort he has
unearthed so much material not just
about granted about people whose lives
into sacred ground that he's been able
to demolish a lot of myths and untangle
a lot of stories of Mount grant so that
it may be half true but a half untrue he
has produced what I think is one of the
the best sets with presidential papers
of any major figure and some people say
the Madison papers are the best others
say the Jefferson papers are the best
but I certainly don't think that anyone
has done a better job than John Simon
was the grant papers one hundred years
from now
anyone who's interested in grant he's
got to be using those volumes and I got
to be in debt to John Simon just as I
you dedicate the book of dr. John
sellers who has helped countless writers
on the Civil War who's he John solace is
the Library of Congress's own Civil War
specialists and John helps a lot of
people including me but the reason I
dedicated the book to him is that John
was in a way the first person to
encourage me to write this book my
closer to my editor he said it sounds
like good idea nice said so then I went
to ask John who I didn't know up until
then and I think dr. sells what do you
think of this like this is excellent you
should do it if William McFeely was
sitting here would you if you two were
ever if you ever got together would it
be a constant argument about grant that
depends I think I'm professor make food
I mean but did you find yourself
constantly disagreeing with him as you
read his book yes I did but I think the
biggest flaw in that book maybe
something that was identified by
reviewing the New York Times when that
book came out
who said grants only appears in
professor McFeely's book four or five
times there's a loss of material that I
granted a lot of opinion on grants the
demand seems to be missing this picture
here will show in just a second
it's hard to see us grin the middle ear
he's there where is this this is the
Great Temple of Karnak at Karnak in
Egypt grants is wearing a pith helmet
but then it appears to have a towel on
top of it to cover his neck it's not a
talent but it's it's a pieces of cloth
Julia is sitting next to him and appears
to be looking at the ground the young
man to the right of Center this
photograph was sitting down has his
hands on the head of a small boy that
young man is Fred Grant who had
graduated from West Point and left the
army and is now traveling around doing
some of this around the world watch with
his parents two and a half years around
the world was he out there away from
this country for all that time oh yes if
he found an easy way to go to Australia
he would have been gone even longer who
paid for that he did what years did he
have what was that the eighteen well he
leaves the White House in March of 1877
and two months later
bon voyage and he's got to turn a few
years do you find a lot of material on
that trip yes and no there are some
losses there was a lot of material
booties mostly in the in the book the
two the two massive volumes written by
the journalist who went around the world
with him John Russell young and young
and Grant had a lot of conversations
during that voyage the conversations are
fascinating many of the reflections on
the Civil War Grant there was nothing
grants like better than to sit around
and reminisce about Mexico and the Civil
War where did he go
during those two and a half years well
him he went to nearly every country in
Europe and Western Europe and he went to
Russia and he went to and he he went to
Egypt which he liked probably better
than almost any other place because up
to that point went to Jerusalem sailed
on to India went to China with Hong Kong
Shanghai how is he receiving this place
well he was received offices if he was a
president he not nobody done this kind
of thing before grant he was wherever he
was received he was received as a great
soldier and he astounded his hosts by
refusing to go to military reviews he
hated parades and he he wouldn't even
look at pictures of military art if he
could avoid it he traveled on to Japan
which strange it was the one place where
he wasn't able to avoid a military
review and from there he wanted to go to
Australia but there was no way of going
to Australia without stopping at a lot
of other places along the way and Julia
did not like travelling and in fact
Julie said Ulysses I've had enough of
this I want to go home and he wanted to
go to Australia had there been had there
been a way of saving directly from Japan
to Australia and you would have
that was impossible so he resigned
himself to sailing to Hawaii and then on
to San Francisco what year is this
picture taken 1883 mistaken only a few
days before Grant died he's working on
his memoirs where is he this is Mount
McGregor leaving the small cottage up in
upstate New York near Saratoga that
belonged to one of the Vanderbilts
what's he dying of dying of throat
cancer was it doing well it's an act it
was an agonizing way to die the doctor
would give paint cocaine on this
cancerous growth during the day in an
attempt to ease the pain and then he had
morphine at night to help him sleep but
even the muffing some English difference
the pain was so agonizing what was his
financial position then well he died
virtually a pauper but the that he had
signed all the rights to his his
manuscript his memoirs over to Julian so
that his creditors from the failed
business in New York wouldn't be able to
seize the royalties from his book so he
gave the manuscript to Julia and then
the literary rights in it became hers
and the creditors couldn't claim them so
he hadn't when he died he had nothing
and somehow that too is all of the piece
with is Grant's life the fact they never
really had a home of his own that he was
not interested in possessions fame power
he left the world about as poor as when
he'd arrived and in the end how many
copies of the memoirs sold well now
because the number would be in the
millions but at the time that first that
subscription issue close to 500,000 in
that couple as we have remaining did I
read it right that when he went to
Appomattox that three of his groomsmen
people that stood at his wedding on his
side supporting him were on the other
side that's right
namely people like James Longstreet and
Marcellus will chuff did you find a lot
of evidence that that was significance
to him that they had gone to the other
side well he he married into a family
that owned slaves
Colonel dent the self stomp channel then
at 18 flags Julie his wife had four when
they went to Galena however just for the
Civil War she had to leave her for
slaves behind because Illinois was a
free state so grant was grant had many
friends on the side on the other side
friends and acquaintances on the other
side of the Great Divide in the Civil
War and that he never allowed that kind
of thing to spoil his relationship with
people he was opposed to slavery so
being something evil but his friendship
was his Longstreet was not affected by
that and he was and his relationship
with his wife of the second fella by the
way or any bit any voice recordings
anywhere no I don't think there are any
recordings before the 1890s of anyone
when is your eisenhower book due out
when I finish it which will probably
take me a few years it's going to be a
pretty that's a major project where is
this picture on the cover ironically
this picture was taken states of shame
grant looking confident and optimistic
was taken the day before one of the
worst days in his life Jared this was
taken at cold hub in June of 1864 and
the next day the Union the Army of the
Potomac made a futile and very costly
frontal assault on Confederate lines
that called Harvard in the space of less
than an hour suffered 7,000 about 7,000
casualties
folks wonder they're going to have to
read to find out more we're out of time
Jeffrey parrot Parra excuse me I haven't
sorry we didn't get to pick the
difference in the names thank you very
much for
joining us author of us ulysses s grant
soldier and president thank you